Stephen you Lackey is a documentary
filmmaker a former HBO studio executive
a feature producer and most recently
Dean of the school of film and
television at Loyola Marymount
University the last eight years this
past June he stepped down from LMU and
weeks later was accepted into the
Academy enjoy the nickel fellowships
committee presenting the award to
allison buck melter and the glissberg
melter is Steven you'll act I just
wanted to say that this script that we
are about to talk about is a script that
I had I think I ever read a script quite
like it and given the political times
and we live in it was a script that for
me performed there remarkable
I mean a remarkable effect it actually
started off with your being in the mind
you have a liberal conventional liberal
political activist and then actually
managed to transport you into an
understanding of a right-wing
survivalist and it was all done with
great craft and great great skill and it
was a as I said it was a story that was
beautifully beautifully put together and
what happened was something I mean I'm
focusing on the political part of it but
it was a very human dramatic story that
you were reading and you were watching
and all I can say is that it's the kind
of script that absolutely should be made
into a film given the times we live in
because it's something that does talk
about crossing the divide that exists in
this country and I want to congratulate
those authors of that script for it
I need to ask them to come up Alice and
Buck melter and Nicolas buck melter the
writing team
[Laughter]
Thank You Steven um for that kind
introduction and um thanks to Joan why
Kris Carr Qi Jenn Nelson and these
wonderful actors into the nickel
committee who dedicated your
professional lives to making the movies
that inspire us or deeply humbled by the
recognition this fellowship represents
you know back in the charmingly simple
days of 2015
Allison and I were expecting our second
child we were really excited for what
the next year would bring and then we
were dealt a stinging blow of a
miscarriage and doctors put Allison on
bed rest to recover and after some
reflection she said I can't just sit
here in bed feeling devastated I've got
to I've got to do something and so with
her computer on her lap and the mood in
America growing more ominous she began
the first draft of what eventually
became American refugee and although the
two of us worked hard together on this
script it was Allison at the outset who
drew on some hidden reserve of optimism
and found a way to bring light to a very
dark time for us to transform a loss
into a kind of birth and this idea of
finding hope in a troubled time
ultimately became a guiding theme in our
screenplay and so Thank You Allison
my immensely talented and inspirational
partner I'm so honored to share this
fellowship with you
this man next to me is an amazing
husband partner and writer he has a way
of seeing the hidden goodness and so
many things and sometimes when I think
we've done all we can do with this
script he'll he'll say we can make this
better and he finds a way so thank you
Nick for the hope the belief and the
willingness to see it through to the end
we'd also like to thank our friends Dean
Wyden Minh Sherman and meredith q Daniel
and Tony at sea Andrew Chan and Nigel
Campbell who've been champions of our
writing from early on and also thank you
to Martin Spencer and Ethan Neil
paradigm and Justin Lippmann and Peter
McHugh at Gotham group your guidance is
already proving invaluable to my parents
Kate and David thank you for encouraging
me to pack up my Ford Escort wagon this
summer after college and head down to LA
even though you knew the road would be
long and difficult you never doubted it
would all be worth it or if you did you
never said so and finally big thanks to
to my parents as well
lou and jerome for all your help with
the children but more importantly for
the steady encouragement that you've
provided since before I could hold a
pencil I love you guys thank you so much
everyone
[Applause]